leur message est sans équivoque
syndicalistes et riverains du quartier
de la gare de plaisir disent non à la
fermeture de la poste annexe acté il y a
trois jours cette fermeture était prévue
depuis plusieurs semaines
problème de rentabilité selon la poste
en argument que réfute la cgt la poste
c'est un service public
ça doit permettre l'accès équitable de
tous les usagers à ce service donc il
faut des bureaux de proximité et les la
stratégie les choix ne doivent pas être
fait uniquement en tout cas non il doit
pas du tout est fait ça des critères de
rentabilité mise en cause également pour
avoir donné son accord la mairie se
défend et met en avant un service plus
performant et mieux adapté le nouveau
bureau de poste relais sera notamment
ouvert 7 jours sur 7
peut-être une demi-journée dans la main
pour qui ce genre de hockey
par contre la proposition qui était fait
et de saint phalle et supermarchés pas
oubli qui est plus centrale et avec une
amplitude horaire
et puis alors au supermarché
la nouvelle poste relais situé dans le
centre commercial brigitte est ouverte
du lundi au samedi entre 8h30 et 20h30
et le dimanche entre 9h et 13h